Seven subtle signs a shy girl likes you
Not everyone is as confident or outgoing as Elle Woods from Legally Blonde
Instead of wearing bold bright pink every day some girls might shy away from that and wear more muted tones
for a shy person
common struggles
they face are public speaking going to parties and of course confessing their feelings to someone they like
Are you wondering if you're shy co-worker, a friend, or classmate likes you? here are seven signs a shy girl likes you
1. she fidgets and adjusts her clothes. girls want to look good in front of their crush
So if you find her smoothing her skirt or combing her fingers through her hair
Know that she's making an effort to look attractive for you
If you find her fidgeting with her fingers too, it means she's nervous around you. help her relax and show her
It's okay to be silly with you
2. she finds small excuses to be around you. a shy girl will rarely ever outwardly ask you out on a date
What she'll do instead is find small open windows in your schedule just to be around you
Whether it means hanging out in a group setting or knowing when you'll be at the library or coffee shop
She'll make sure to show up at your favorite spots a shy girl wants to be noticed too. 3. she looks away at first
Strong eye contact is usually a good sign someone's in to you, but shy girls often have a hard time with this one
When you talk to her take note on how quickly she looks away from you
If you notice that she does this frequently it's because she's nervous around you
Eventually though shy girls want to boost their confidence. So the more you talk to her, the better she'll be at holding her gaze
4. she eavesdrops on you
When a girl likes you she'll want to know every little detail about you
She might not be the best at asking questions to you. So watch out
She'll be sleuthing in the background if you catch her
Leaning in as you talk to others or notice that she's asking your friends about you
Chances are she's collecting information to make a good impression
Pretty cute right? 5.  She laughs at your jokes. a girl whether she's shy or not
Will often laugh at a guy's joke when she's into him
Consider it a shy girl's subtle way of flirting with you
Even if you weren't being intentionally funny and she suddenly laughs at what you said
This is a clear indicator that she's into you. people tend to find others funny when they find them attractive. 6.
She interacts with every guy but you.
You might think she's avoided you because she doesn't like you or finds you annoying
But this is actually not the case at all, when a shy girl is into you. She'll feel nervous and awkward when you're around
If you catch her comfortable and at ease around other guys
She could either be trying to make you jealous or has no idea how to act towards you. Don't be discouraged by her flightiness
Instead approach her confidently and see how she behaves
If she acts strange or blushes then this is a clear sign, she likes you. 7. she's more interactive with you online
Shy girls might not be as talkative in person because they're worried about saying something weird
Or unsure about what to talk about
So if you've received lengthy text messages or notice that she's putting effort in to keep the conversation going
Then it's a sure sign. She's into you
Don't worry too much about the time she takes to respond if she's quick then it's a strong giveaway
But if she takes her time know that it's also possible she could be playing hard to get or you know, she could be busy
Too but hey, it makes it all the more obvious. She's taking time to get back to you
Do you think a shy girl likes you? Please share your thoughts with us below. Remember
Shy girls have a hard time being forward. So maybe it's time YOU make a move and ask her out already
She'll be relieved you did it first. For more helpful information
Please check out our video. Five ways women fall in a know also
Don't forget to subscribe for more content from psych to go and check out our patreon. Thanks for watching and good luck
Hey everybody, I just want to give a personal
Thank you video for you guys for always supporting psych to go and making this all possible for us
Our vision is to make psychology as accessible as possible so that it promotes self-awareness and it helps you guys grow
however
We want to make more content for you guys and would love your support and buying one of these bracelets for my partner, Introvert
Palace. check out the bracelet. It's pretty cool
And it even includes Pluto the link to purchase will all be in the description below and I hope you guys have an amazing day
Bye